so every time you bail out a big Silicon
Valley Bank or a Wall Street big firm
which you wouldn't do for a mid-size or
small company or Bank whenever you bail
them out citizens everywhere else not
just in the US but around the world
since we've got the dollar they pay for
that and it shouldn't happen so then it
sounds like let's just let them fall
they should I mean Bannon was saying
that on Friday you know you're selling
Matt Gates and Dan Bishop on this show
resist do not let them convince you to
bail these people out let you know but I
wonder I mean if in 2008 they didn't
bail out any banks what do you think
would have happened uh well no one
really knows but I don't think it would
have been a disaster even in disaster if
the Wall Street firms but who cares I
mean if Goldman Sachs and Merrill Lynch
you name all those firms that they went
under who did they lend to huge Fortune
500 companies who pay outlandish fees
and they're not the only ones who can do
investment banking